so the question isn't only in the danger
but it's kind of the process he's the
mechanism by which we want to actually
secure the good in the world but we try
to secure the good when we claim that we
have knowledge of it we end up
constructing enemies who are opposed to
us
[Music]
should we conclude that dividing the
world into good and bad is not just
misguided but actually dangerous Tommy
yes so
I would have to say that those kinds of
binaries have been utilized throughout
history
largely is an extension of what one
in-group or dominant ethno group has
thought reflects the qualities of
themselves and how they've utilized the
notion of good be it morality or even an
independent system of Ethics by which we
determine what the good the bad or the
evil should be to impose certain kinds
of norms and structures on out groups uh
it's it's fascinating to me because when
you look at the whole history of Western
thought some thinkers like a Rousseau
for instance would say that the idea of
Good and Evil actually originates in
Civilization when one wants to create a
system of Ethics by which we can
evaluate and judge actions and
individuals and ultimately groups he
thought this is one of the failures of
the Arts and Sciences and and the
letters so you're looking at a tendency
not of all of humanity but I think
particularly in Western Humanity to
impose the good as an intuitive that has
a retitive relationship not only to
reason but to being and to see just that
people who exist are the groups that
exist within kind of the illumination of
the good has the right to not only
impose but rule over those who are bad
are evil or don't have the same access
to it and I think this presents a very
important quandary for how we think of
our our contemporary World in modern
civilization because now we're not
simply having philosophical arguments or
debates you know in the Agora are in
forums where we're trying to come to a
consensus about the values that we think
constitute what is the good but rather
we're using economics military might
politics and violence to impress one
specific notion of the good on others
and these hierarchies that we develop
between each other be it an end group or
an out-group been a political party or
otherwise
exuded integration if not dehumanization
of the people we see on the other side
so the question isn't only in the danger
but it's kind of the processes the
mechanism by which we want to actually
secure the good in the world when we try
to secure the good when we claim that we
have knowledge of it we end up
constructing enemies who are opposed to
us so what becomes evil is not something
that is obvious and intentional
something that's a brute fact of nature
that simply imposes itself on other
everyone else equally but rather what a
particular group defines is the evil
that they want to overcome and that
seems to be more akin to people defining
themselves and some ideas that have
God's given right that's been ordained
by something higher than themselves and
us to understand why they have this
natural ordained power to determine how
reality in the world should be so the
question of Good and Evil isn't one
merely of danger but it's the kind of
caricatures the processes of logic and
reason that are created by the presumed
relationship that we have to morality
even more dangerously to presuppose that
we create rules of this called ethics
that allow us to somehow objectively
Intuit what these forms of morality
would be even at the expense of other
people's existence thank you so much
um Massimo why have we divided should we
conclude that dividing the world into
good and bad is not just misguided but
actually dangerous
yeah it's you will almost say it's evil
right so yeah I don't I don't believe I
don't believe that the categories of
good anymore are particularly useful and
in fact I believe that they tend to be
pernicious let me tell you a couple of
stories to illustrate the point a
colleague of mine Owen Flanagan a number
of years ago interviewed the Dalai Lama
and uh Flanagan was curious about how
the Dalai Lama would react to this
classic thought experiment is that um so
if I had a time machine and I were
allowed to go back in time and kill
Hitler should I not do it and shouldn't
I do it because itra was evil let's
start with Hitler because you know why
why leave the obvious easy case for
later
and the Dalai Lama's response and on top
of that Owen said should I also not be
angry about about it right that's that's
what motivates me I I know what ether
did and I get angry and that's I go back
in in time and kill him the Dalai Lama's
response was you absolutely should go
back and kill Hitler and in fact you
should do a fun fair you should organize
a sort of a party a ceremony because
this is an important thing that you're
doing you're actually going to be very
helpful but no you should absolutely not
be angry about it you should approach
the issue as if you were a surgeon
excising a tumor the surgeon isn't going
to be upset about the tumor isn't going
to say two more evil it's just the tumor
is just the thing that happens in the
universe and if we can avoid it if we
can get it out then we should because
it's it's a positive thing it improves
uh human health to do it so that's the
way we should be treating Hitler so the
Dalai Lama was making two points
first of all that yes it is it's not a
question of opinion whether ether was a
positive or A negative in the in the
cosmic Dharma web of Dharma it clearly
was not a good thing that's why you take
get rid of it but at the same time you
shouldn't be upset about it because you
should understand that we are all the
result of complex webs of cause and
effect none of us asked to be here none
of us chose our parents none of us chose
our genetic makeup or our upbringing or
anything like that so if we have
responsibility from an ethical
perspective it's kind of a little tiny
and that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
be held uh responsible for what we do
but we should that should happen with a
certain attitude in mind the Second
Story I want to tell you goes back to
the early second century and to ancient
Rome the historic teacher epictidus was
asked a similar question by one of his
students of course either was not born
yet Khalid was
um but you know same thing and the
student asked um you know so if I see
these you know these really bad person
should I not you know put him in jail or
or kill him or anything like that and
epideo's response was well think of the
bad person what you are calling a bad
person as a blind man
the blind man is going down the street
and he's likely to hurt himself and bump
into others possibly hurt other people
but you wouldn't go in there and put him
in jail or kill him what you're going to
do is first of all to make sure that it
doesn't hurt other people and second of
all if possible to make sure that it
doesn't hurt himself and perhaps even
help him to you know be cured of his
blindness that's the way you should
approach things and it's the same with
every every human behavior so the result
the the upshot of all of this is that
categories like good and evil are not
helpful because they tend to be
dichotomous they tend to create this
sharp distinction and obviously we are
always the good ones right it's always
the other side of this band you know
we're not evil
uh they're not helpful they are in fact
pernicious because they prompt us to act
in a way that is unchartedable that is
uncaring to other people what we should
try to do instead is to be helpful and
yes sometimes to be helpful does mean uh
intervene in a certain way and perhaps
even you know you know you know violent
firm way but only as the last resort and
always with the right attitude of
Charity toward other human beings who
are pretty much in the same boat as as
we are thank you so much
um Joanna over to you should we conclude
that dividing the world into good and
bad is not just misguided but actually
dangerous thank you so there's a whole
very ancient tradition of people talking
about what might be a good way to be how
to be a good person how to act well and
how to treat others well and these terms
good and bads originally they're they
come from a old Germanic tradition of
language and they're quite practical in
their original use this idea of bad it's
very much about a misfortune or a
disease as Massimo was saying something
that's going to cause harm and similarly
with good there's this idea it's a
benefit or a gift so they don't have
this adamantine absolute system this
idea that they connect to some elsewhere
beyond the humor that can't be argued
with that can never ever be counted so I
think that tradition of debating
how to live well how to treat others
well is obviously incredibly important
and we want to be able to act in the
world and to counter where we see harm
and Misfortune and as you were saying
this disease and so throughout history
you have that debate and it goes all the
way back to 2000 years before Christ the
Epic of Gilgamesh through you know the
Greeks and through further societies and
ages that we'll touch on
but I think also then you have those
people who are trying to control
everything as we've heard from Tommy
that they're they're trying to just
sanction their own activities with
reference to this absolute realm that
can't be counted and I think you get
these crisis points then consistently
where people try to react against this
and William Blake
existing in the 18th century in a
society where slave labors the slave
trade is still operating child labor is
being used as massive iniquities poverty
and he just says your terminology is
completely corrupt you argue that this
is the good and your entire system of
values has failed utterly and so I will
do something else I'll create another
version of values so I think we don't
want to fall into a trap that's often
set for us in this debate that if we
don't accept that absolute realm then we
can't debate the terms we can all debate
and intervene and discuss and Adrian
Rich talks about this this idea of moral
responsibility is refusing to let others
do the naming and the talking for you
you you join the conversation and you
invite others to join so I definitely
argue for that for debating which I
guess is what we're doing so that would
be my argument to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas